دعونا نحضر وزيرة الخارجية الأردنية
إيمان السافار، يسعدنا أن نستضيفكم
بيان الملك عبد الله في أعقاب ذلك
الانفجار الذي وقع في المستشفى والذي يشير
بإصبع الاتهام بشكل مباشر إلى إسرائيل، هل ما
زال الأردن يعتقد أن الانفجار
نتج عن غارة جوية إسرائيلية،
مساء الخير بيكي  أه هذه الضربة
كما قلت إنها جريمة بشعة
إنها جريمة حرب أه الجميع هنا أه
يعتقد أن إسرائيل هي المسؤولة
عنها والجيش يقول إنها ليست إلا ولكن لكي
نكون صادقين حاول أن تجد أي شخص
سيصدق ذلك  جزء من
العالم أه الناس معتادون على أه هذا النوع
من أه أه إنكار الأشياء ومن ثم
الاعتراف بها كلنا نتذكر حالة
شيرين أبو حيث كان أول
رد إسرائيلي هو أن الفلسطينيين هم من
قتلوها ثم انتهى بهم الأمر إلى
الاعتراف بأن ذلك كان  جندي إسرائيلي أه
أعتقد أه لن يصدق أحد
تلك القصة أه الناس غاضبون لأنك
أه فقط أبلغت أعتقد أه هل
إسرائيل مستعدة لإجراء تحقيق مستقل أه
أه دولي
في الجريمة حتى يتم ذلك حتى لا يقوم أحد
في المنطقة  أعتقد أنها
لم تكن إسرائيل نظرًا لحقيقة أننا
رأينا آلاف الصواريخ أه
تخرج من غزة إلى داخل إسرائيل
ولم يكن أي منها قادرًا على
إحداث أي ضرر حتى بالقرب من أه ال
الضرر الهائل
الذي  رأيت الليلة الماضية، لذا، أيها
الوزير، اسمحوا لي أن أعرض عليكم هذا،
فالتقارير تشير إلى أن المخابرات الأمريكية
الآن تعتقد أيضًا أن هجوم الثلاثاء كان
سببه مجموعة فلسطينية مسلحة
أم، أنت تقف إلى جانب ما قلته
أنه لا أحد يعتقد أن هذا كان
أي شيء سوى  ضربة إسرائيلية
صحيحة أنا لست خبير استخبارات
بيكي أنا فقط أقول لك أنه لا أحد
في هذا الجزء من العالم
سيصدق معلومات استخباراتية مبنية على
المخابرات الإسرائيلية أه إذا كانت إسرائيل
مستعدة لإجراء
تحقيق دولي مستقل  التحقيق في
هذا أه فليفعل ذلك وإذا كان إذا إذا
أه دليل مستقل
يشير إلى خلاف ذلك فسوف نتعامل
مع ذلك إذن ولكن الآن أه بغض النظر
عما تقوله إسرائيل بغض النظر عن المعلومات
الاستخباراتية التي تنتجها أه أنا  أنا فقط
أقول لك أنه في
العالم العربي الإسلامي كله لن يصدق أحد ذلك
بناء على تجارب سابقة أه
وبناء على قضايا سابقة
نفى فيها إسرائيل أولا ثم عندما
سمح بالتحقيقات أه
ظهرت قصة مختلفة أه صحيح
وزير الخارجية أم الأردن ألغي  القمة
التي كان من المفترض أن يحضرها جو بايدن الرئيس الأمريكي
والتي تم
إلغاؤها، كما أفهم، في أعقاب
ذلك الهجوم، لكن هل يمكنك أن تشرح
بالضبط سبب إلغاء الأردن لهذه القمة،
وهل هناك أي ندم على
الفرصة التي كانت ستمنحها
للأردن و  الآخرين ليروا الأمر وجها لوجه
مع
الرئيس الأمريكي فعلا فيكي أه
قرار عدم انعقاد القمة
اليوم وفر فرصة أه
فلا يخطئن في مدى قوة أه
علاقات الأردن معنا على مدى تقدير
جلالته ل  الرئيس أه
تصرفنا أه في الظروف مباشرة
بعد خبر هجوم أه
على المستشفى أه قمنا للتو
بتقييم بالتنسيق أه مع
الفلسطينيين مع الإسرائيليين عباس
قرر الرحيل أجرينا نقاشا طويلا مستفيضا
أه مع ال  الأمريكان
وتوصلنا إلى أن
البطاقة الرئاسية مكتب
الرئيس أه مهمة جدا
أمريكا أه تلعب دورا رئيسيا ليس فقط في في
إدارة
الكارثة الحالية والتعامل معها ولكن لاحقا لذلك
أعتقد  الجميع أه توصل إلى
نتيجة أه أه أنه من الأفضل ألا
يكون الرئيس في هذه
الظروف لأن ما كان الناس
يتوقعونه هو قرار إنهاء الحرب
أه ذلك القرار لم يكن واضحا وشيك
أه مرة أخرى بعد
التشاور والنقاش مع
مصر و و  والفلسطينيين
وبعد نقاش مستفيض مع
الولايات المتحدة اتخذنا قرار أه أه عدم
عقد القمة الآن الأمريكيون
فهموا أه والآن نعمل
والاتصالات استمرت
وتستمر بيننا وبين أمريكا أه
للقيام  متأكد من أننا نخلق فرصة
عندما يكون التواجد في
المنطقة أه هو قادر على إيصال الأخبار
التي ينتظرها الجميع هنا وهو
إنهاء هذه الحرب وإنقاذ المدنيين
و و و و والبدء في النظر في كيف
يمكننا أن نصنع معًا أه كيف  يمكننا البدء في
البناء من أجل شرق أوسط أفضل،
والدور الرئيسي للولايات المتحدة لا
غنى عنه ودورها القيادي هو
الدور الرئيسي. حسنًا، أريد أن أتحدث معك
حول الطريقة التي تقترح بها أن هذه الحرب التي
تعرفها قد تنتهي أو قد تنتهي.
قد يكون هناك نوع من التوقف المؤقت في
هذه المرحلة ولكن يجب أن أسألك، هل
تعلم أننا رأينا متظاهرين في
شوارع الأردن خارج
السفارة الإسرائيلية، أعني أن الصور موجودة
ونراها في جميع أنحاء المنطقة.
فوضوي جدًا مما
نفهمه من الفريق الموجود على الأرض
الشرطة تستخدم الغاز المسيل للدموع لتفريق الناس
فقط ما مدى قلقك من أن الأردن
يواجه الآن تهديدًا خطيرًا للأمن القومي
أه بيكي الناس غاضبون
الجميع غاضب أه 11 فلسطينيًا
أه أه مدنيون يقتلون كل  ساعة على يد
الإسرائيليين يقتل خمسة أطفال
كل ساعة على يد الإسرائيليين تقتل امرأتين
كل ساعة على يد الإسرائيليين ال ال ال
الضحايا في هذه
الحرب أه أعلى من الضحايا في
حربي 2014 التي استمرت 50
يوما لذلك الناس  غاضبون لكن الناس
يعلمون أن الأردن ليس العدو وأن
الأردن يبذل كل ما في وسعه أه
لوقف هذه الحرب التي قالت إن حجم
الغضب ليس فقط في الأردن وفي كل مكان آخر
بما في ذلك الضفة الغربية بما في ذلك
مصر يتصاعد وما لم أه نحن'  نحن
قادرون على إيقاف هذه الكارثة التي
سيتصاعد الغضب فيها وأعتقد أننا جميعًا
سندفع الثمن أه
انظر إلى التأثير الاقتصادي انظر إلى
سعر الفائدة الذي يمر عبر
السماء، لذا فهو أمر جدي والناس
أريد أن أسمع شيئًا واحدًا وشيئًا واحدًا
فقط قرارًا بوقف الحرب،
نعم، كما ترى، ترى بوضوح أن هذا
يمثل تهديدًا للأمن القومي
لبلدك وما هو أبعد من ذلك، أريد أن أسألك
ما رأيك في الأخبار التي لدينا
في الساعة الماضية فقط،
وافقت إسرائيل على السماح بدخول المساعدات الإنسانية إلى
غزة من مصر، هل هذا بقدر ما
يمكنك قوله وربما يمكنك أن تعرف
أنك أجريت محادثات خلف
الكواليس ويمكنك تأكيد أن
هذا هو  الاتفاق الضمني من قبل
الإسرائيليين لوقف مؤقت لإطلاق النار هو
أن ما يعنيه هذا في هذه
المرحلة بيكي أعني أننا جميعًا نعمل
على إيجاد أي بصيص من الأمل في هذا
الظلام أه نحن جميعًا نعمل من أجل
وقف إطلاق النار الذي يسمح أه
بتسليم  إمدادات إنسانية أه
للغزيين نبحث عن
ممر إنساني يوصل
الأدوية الغذائية أه الإمدادات الأخرى
للغزيين لدينا مستشفى يعمل في
غزة منذ 2009 خلال أسبوع
ستنفذ أه الإمدادات ولن
يتمكن من ذلك  نعمل لذا اه لم نر
ذلك يحدث إذا حدث ذلك فهذه
خطوة أولى اه لتقليل
ما يعتبر جريمة حرب من خلال حرمان الناس من
الوصول إلى الغذاء والماء اه نحن جميعًا
وراء ذلك نحن جميعًا وراء
وقف إطلاق النار  أه نحن جميعا بحاجة إلى أن نتأمل
ونقول كفى كم من الناس
سيموتون قبل أن ندرك جميعا
أن الحرب لن تحل المشكلة أن
الحرب لن تضمن أمن إسرائيل
أو أمن الفلسطينيين أو أمننا
أه في ذلك فقط السلام سيحل  سوف نفعل ذلك
لذلك أه الحديث عن وقف إطلاق النار مستمر الحديث
عن أه السماح بالإمدادات
مستمر الحديث عن قرار إنهاء
الحرب مستمر لذلك نحن جميعًا نعمل
على ذلك وأي خطوة في هذا
الاتجاه هي بالتأكيد خطوة مرحب بها
سيكون لها  تأثير حقيقي من
حيث إنقاذ حياة الناس، لقد
تحدثت أنت وأنا منذ بضعة أيام
وقلتم بشكل فعال إن الأردن لديه
خط أحمر عندما يتعلق الأمر بأي
فلسطيني أم يبحث عن مخرج
عبر رفح أم إلى مصر
والأردن  أعني أن هناك دائمًا هذا الخوف
في الأردن من أن الولايات المتحدة
وإسرائيل قد تحاولان جعل الأردن
الوطن البديل للشعب
الفلسطيني المعروف باسم وطن الليل
باللغة العربية بدلاً من السماح
بتشكيل دولة فلسطينية فعلية في
ضوء ما  إننا نشهد
تهجير الفلسطينيين في الوقت الحالي،
والضغط الذي تم ممارسته
عليك لقبول الفلسطينيين عبر
معبر رفح الحدودي هو مصدر
قلق للأردن في هذه
المرحلة. بيكي، هذه رواية قديمة
تستمر في الظهور وموقفنا
هو  حازمون على أننا لن نسمح أبدًا
بنقل سكان آخر وهو
بالمناسبة جريمة حرب بموجب القانون الدولي
بموجب اتفاقية جنيف
وبروتوكولها لعام 1977 جريمة حرب أه لذلك هذا
شيء لن
نقبله ولن نسمح لإسرائيل به
نقل الأزمة إلى الأردن أه إذا كان
هناك أي محاولة حقيقية لفعل ذلك
فالفلسطينيون لا يريدون ذلك الأردنيون
لا يريدون ذلك فما سيفعله هو
دعني أكون صادقا ستكون مجرد حرب أخرى
في المنطقة أه  سوف يوسع
منطقة الصراع، فهو لن يجلب
السلام، لذا مرة أخرى لا تخطئوا عندما يتعلق الأمر
بأن موقفنا لا يتزعزع،
فلن نسمح أبدًا
بنقل السكان من فلسطين إلى الأردن،
وهذا سيأخذ الصراع إلى
بعد جديد تمامًا  سيكون
خطيرا وكارثيا أه على
المنطقة كلها لذلك لا لن يحدث
الوطن الفلسطيني على أه على
ترابهم الوطني
حل الدولتين هو السبيل الوحيد للمضي قدما على
إسرائيل أن تفهم أن العالم
يجب أن يفهم أنه  يكفي واسمحوا
لي أن أحذر من شيء هنا بيكي ونحن
نقول ذلك كدولة تعرف أه
لديها علاقات جيدة هائلة مع جميع
أصدقائنا وحلفائنا الغربيين والتصور
المتزايد في الشارع وهم
يرون هذا الدعم السحابي الحديدي الذي لا لبس فيه
للإسراء لإسرائيل  في هذه الحرب، هناك
تصور متزايد بأن هذه
حرب عربية إسلامية غربية، وهذا مكان
لا نريد الوصول إليه، وهو مكان
يجب علينا جميعًا أن نعمل على منع
دخوله، ولهذا السبب
يجب أن تصمت الأسلحة.  يجب أن
يعود السبب يجب أن تعود العقلانية
ونكتشف طريقة للخروج من هذا
الظلام اتخذنا موقفا واضحا في
إدانة قتل المدنيين وعلى
العالم أن يفعل ذلك وإلا فإنه
يخاطر أه بمساواته بالجرائم
التي ترتكب  نحن نفعل ذلك
لأننا نهتم بالسلام لأننا
عملنا جميعًا من أجل السلام، وهذه هي
مهمة صاحب الجلالة أه،
نستمر في محاولة العمل من أجل السلام دون توقف، لقد حان الوقت
لنستمع إلى محاولة تغيير
الصراع مما سيؤدي إلى تفاقم
الأمر  خطر توسع هذه الحرب إلى
الضفة الغربية إلى أجزاء أخرى من
المنطقة أه حقيقي يجب أن نوقف
ذلك قبل فوات الأوان علينا جميعا
وزير الخارجية الأردني أنا
الصفدي لا أتقن كلامك
وهذا مفهوم  نشكرك كثيرًا
حقًا على انضمامك إلينا